working game my opponent made 49 moves  and then blunded his Rook on move 50 but  before I had time to take it I had to  make my 50th move and take it on the  51st and he claimed the drug claimed the  draw hole and uh he printed pretended he  did it by accident  okay the game unless I'm coming wrong it  should be a draw after black after  Black's move now maybe Chucky wants to  play on a little bit no Chucky  it is a draw after  123 moves in 17 minutes two legends in  chess the great was live on shook with a  sigh of relief he gets a draw against  world number one Magnus Carlsen a great  game how will you describe this game  David  uh a roller coaster a promotion and just  high quality there was one opportunity  for Magnus to win on the spot we should  mention Magnus saw that as soon as he uh  missed it but  um yeah in general Fair result both  players two Warriors battling it up